I think there's a big challenge in
public health all the time when you're
looking at the common good which often
imposes on individual rights why would
we want the government to be in control
of our weight the weight of the nation
has been making headlines lately thanks
to a Washington conference and an HBO
documentary using that very title we did
use policy we could use the marketplace
through taxation to really shape
purchasing behaviors some would argue
that we have to employ the same tactics
to really reshape our food environment
the piece is based on the Institute of
medicines nearly five hundred page
report rejecting the idea that
individual willpower is to blame for the
obesity epidemic their solution is a
series of dramatic and systematic
measures but will these government
interventions actually solve the problem
it's an access issue that we live in an
obesogenic environment and that as long
as we have ready access to cheap
affordable low nutritious foods that is
gonna have an impact on our BC levels
dr. Lisa Santora is the chief medical
officer of Southern California's beach
cities Health District the largest
health prevention agency in the country
she wants more government dollars to
help fight obesity prevention is under
attack probably on a monthly basis right
now to take away those funds and to
apply it towards deficit reduction but
my perspective as a preventive medicine
specialist is that we have to make these
investments now the government is
already in a full-fledged war against
obesity with President Obama's health
care reform including 15 billion dollars
for obesity prevention and the
government has been intervening in
nutrition long before the Obama
administration arguably since founding
of the USDA and people have just gotten
heavier with nearly two-thirds of adults
now overweight or obese giving
responsibility away from the person and
putting it onto the government's hand is
usually a pretty bad recipe Cal Poly
economics professor michael marlow says
that prevention programs all over the
country are missing the mark like this
childhood obesity prevention program
that dr. Santora oversees these efforts
don't work they send the wrong signal
the program's called live while kids and
includes the student Grimm gardens
workout programs and produce and local
schools as part of the health districts
tax funded ten million dollar operating
budget every day children have a salad
bar and they have access to what we know
is nutritious food if you talk to most
people they know that they should be
green beans and not a bag of potato
chips it's not necessarily a knowledge
problem yet they're using an approach
that would indicate that people don't
know what's healthy like this
nutritionist teaching parents how to
tell their kids which foods are natural
and which are fake not sure that we
really need to have people trained in
that sort of endeavor but programs are
going beyond trying to increase
awareness this new york billboard of an
obese amputee is part of a massive
government ad campaign to scare people
into behaving a certain way what's wrong
with it is that it's based on
paternalism what they're saying is the
following that the obese don't really
understand the health consequences of
their obesity that they have little
incentive to deal with the obesity
without government so the government
tries a multi-pronged approach but ends
up just stabbing at thin air this has
resulted in a very broad definition of
what constitutes fighting obesity and it
can justify almost any type of spending
such as this federal funding for pets
bang and neutering in Nashville the
project was approved to prevent stray
dogs from scaring people away from
exercising outdoors
another one of the many problems with
government intervention is that it's
usually a one-size-fits-all system
that's susceptible to corruption pizza
is currently a vegetable there's been a
lobbying effort by businesses to promote
their products having the food police if
you will come in and tell you what is a
good lunch and what is not a good lunch
is a recipe for disaster
like when a North Carolina state
employee decided that a preschoolers
lunch
featuring a turkey sandwich was not
nutritious enough in accordance with
USDA guidelines the student was given
chicken nuggets instead I think there's
a big challenge in public health all the
time when you're looking at the common
good do you want to create a healthy
environment but then sometimes that can
impose on individual rights where you
say well you can't bring soda to school
you can't have that and you have to
really strike that balance while these
programs mean well they often lack
evidence backing them up banning soda or
other junk food in schools is a good
example it's supposed to steer kids away
from unhealthy food but there's evidence
to the contrary one study reported by
the American Sociological Association
showed that weight gain really doesn't
have anything to do with the junk food
that could be purchased in schools you
can come in and try to control one's
eating habit at school but that isn't
controlling how they substitute when
they go home but the government still
wants to get rid of it and when the
government realizes that programs like
these aren't working it only leads to
more aggressive programs that still
won't fix the problem what do you do
when you see that your good intentions
haven't worked you will then say hey
look what we need to do is to push them
a little harder so we'll raise the taxes
more maybe we should ban certain foods
we're going to come in with a hammer
next time and really make you change
your behavior